[Musique]
quelle province compte le plus de forêts
traités au glyphosate la colombie
britannique n'est pas la seule province
à utiliser le glyphosate pour se
débarrasser de ces feuillus c'est sa
voisine l'alberta qui arrive en tête des
superficies traité près de trente deux
mille hectares de forêts ont été
pulvérisés là-bas en 2017
le nouveau brunswick est la deuxième
province qui compte les plus grandes
superficies arrosée à l'herbicide
mais comme elle est beaucoup plus petit
c'est une plus grande proportion des
forêts qui est aspergé au
nouveau-brunswick une opposition de plus
en plus fortes se fait entendre
pour lutter contre ces pulvérisations
des résidents s'inquiètent notamment de
la contamination de l'eau suite à
l'épandage de l'herbicide selon les
données officielles au canada depuis
1990 ce sont près de 3,5 millions
d'hectares de forêts qui ont été
pulvérisés au glyphosate
le québec a pour sa part banni la
pratique elle n'a plus cours depuis 2001
si le contrôle de la végétation est
nécessaire on opte pour le
débroussaillage mécanique